I came to Stanford to explore
transformation it is what matters most
to me and is a word that has caused me
as much pain as it is pride I'm not
alone society is as obsessed with
transformation as I am
we're fascinated by the before and after
who you were then and who you are now
on Instagram it's the ten year challenge
in nature it's the caterpillar turns
butterfly I've spent my career in
education facilitating change as a
mixed-race Jewish woman I wanted to
ensure that organizations changed to
embrace marginalized voices so I worked
for organizations that created
transformative experiences while they
were undergoing drastic internal change
things like scaling local to national
transitioning CEOs infusing equity and
inclusion I had a front-row seat to
transformation of all kinds it showed me
that even the experts still struggle to
create and define transformation and
that's the thing do any of us really
know what transformation means when we
say it because if we want to change
lives organizations and the world we
need to start defining how we do it I'm
here to end the before and after
dichotomy I want to shift us from seeing
transformation as an outcome to a
process and there's no process more
famous no transformation metaphor more
cliched then the caterpillar turns
butterfly
I actually love this metaphor and as a
former elementary school science teacher
I'm very familiar with it the
caterpillar to butterfly captures
transformations magic and mystery yet
what happens inside the chrysalis face
is unquestioned unheard-of and untouched
and that's the mistake we should be
talking about the chrysalis the true
hero the chrysalis holds the key to how
we can define transformation so let's
focus on the chrysalis because what
happens inside is absolutely
mind-blowing a caterpillar makes her
chrysalis from the inside out to prepare
she anchors herself to a home usually a
twig
she then bursts her head open to shed
her skin the underlying layer is the
chrysalis the chrysalis protects her and
camouflages with the outside worlds with
the hope that no one notices what's
about to happen inside the chrysalis she
then actively breaks down
she liquefies turning completely into
mush the only thing left are her
essential structures for breathing yet
even as mush she knows how to rebuild
she builds each structure carefully her
legs her wings the patterns on her body
and when ready she breaks free until
finally she can fly
when caterpillars break down they know
how to create new better versions of
themselves they can even remember their
time as a caterpillar once they became a
butterfly what they smelled what they
liked what scared them at each step this
transformation is active messy
intentional and personal this is how we
can define transformation this is the
magic and I've learned this firsthand
I experienced a couple of personal
transformations it took me years to
truly accept my identity as a black and
white Jewish woman yet what truly taught
me the process of transformation to
define it in real time was of all things
a bad breakup a couple years ago I was
ending a five-year relationship starting
a new job and learning to live in a new
city feelings of finding myself were
front and center I was angry I was sad
and I was surrounded by people that
created transformation every day how do
you do that I never got that question
answered which is why I'm here
waxing nature metaphors and divulging my
story of liquefying
we need to talk about the breakdown I
went through the same steps as that
caterpillar step 1 I incurred the San
Francisco Bay Area and later Stanford
transformation often happens in these
immersive learning experiences because
you're rooted in a place to do the work
step 2 shed skin and form protection I
simultaneously switched jobs moved ended
their relationship and applied to
business school in many ways my
chrysalis has been my business school
experience from application to today
step 3
breakdown I definitely broke I sat alone
and slept alone I cried every single day
I screamed I don't scream I laid on my
bedroom floor my version of mush I was
so lost step 4 thoughtfully put yourself
back together
I found B I started writing again after
five years poetry mostly and letters I
write in my wrongs and accepted there
were wrongs that I would never be able
to write I practiced presence balance
and gratitude I actively intentionally
changed for the better
step 5
break free fly and remember where you
came from to be honest I'm not here yet
I'm in the messy mushy middle and I love
being in my chrysalis
it gives me direction for one to say yes
and no and for how to prepare for what's
next that's the process and we can all
prepare for what's next because it's so
much more than my transformation its
life so many of us are at Stanford to
search for transformation to welcome it
to facilitate it yet we don't just come
to Stanford to be transformed we do the
work we thoughtfully choose
opportunities that constitute our legs
and wings our careers and organizations
maybe we're all in the messy middle at
Stanford and as a society right now we
have the power and process to be better
because we can do more than change lives
organizations in the world we can
transform them but it won't be enough to
repeat the words we're gonna have to
break them and ourselves all the way
down in order to build back up into
something beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]